a missile that can be launched from a
train or a hypersonic one that can evade
defenses these are some of the newest
weapons in north korea's arsenal which
is already stocked with nuclear bombs
and intercontinental ballistic missiles
that could reach anywhere on the us
mainland so what they're investing in is
to make these missiles as creative and
surprising as possible
it's all part of north korean leader kim
jong-un's promise to build an invincible
military
and the growing number of weapons is
drawing attention from the u.s and its
allies in the region it's all part of a
strategy for north korea to show that
despite years of sanctions and the
struggles of kovid that at least in
terms of military it remains strong
so here's a rundown of some of the
latest technology in north korea's
arsenal and what message its expansion
sends to the world
north korean weapons tests have taken
place under all three generations of the
kim family leadership the country
launched its first homegrown missile in
1984 but the frequency of the tests
spiked under kim jong-un and included
one of the largest ever launched by the
country
tests slowed during the pandemic but in
september of this year north korea
unveiled a new weapon that would be the
first in a quick succession of tests
most recently we've seen things like
long-range cruise missiles melissa
hanham researches weapons of mass
destruction at stanford university's
center for international security and
cooperation she's been closely watching
the activity in east asia for 15 years
they're almost like a small airplane
that can turn corners fly
through valleys and most importantly fly
beneath and around radar
hanham says this quality makes a
long-range cruise missile different from
a ballistic missile which can often
carry a heavier payload and is typically
shot into space with a rocket then falls
in a faster but more predictable
trajectory
the cruise missile on the other hand can
evade detection and stealthily hit a
target
south korea itself has been building up
very powerful hyunmu cruise missiles
some of which they have touted
historically could hit kim jong-un so in
a way
north korea is probably trying to keep
pace with the missiles coming out of
south korea
about two weeks after the launch of the
long-range cruise missile north korea
said it tested another new weapon
zero
it goes much much faster than a cruise
missile that's why they emphasize
hypersonic
hypersonic missiles generally can fly a
mile per second traveling about five
times the speed of sound it can maneuver
and then dart down through the
atmosphere again in such a way that it
would be very hard for ballistic missile
defenses to track and then intercept
and so it's a way of overwhelming and
beating us ballistic missile defenses
here you can see the hypersonic missile
on display while kim jong-un surveyed
his expanding arsenal in october
south korea's military said that the
apparent hypersonic missile appears to
be in an early stage of development but
hanhem says the regime will continue
working on more nimble missiles that can
carry nuclear warheads
north korea is thought to only have a
few warheads and that means that they
need to find creative ways to deliver
these warheads overseas
and kim jong-un has declared that they
will have a multitude of ways of
delivering these
that also means having missile
deployment systems and the regime
scientists have also been working on new
projects
in september state media released
footage of two short-range ballistic
missiles being launched from a train
the idea behind it isn't really that
it's a more powerful missile or faster
missile the idea is that it's a sneaky
missile and that's thanks to the
country's extensive railway network
which stretches from the demilitarized
zone that separates the two koreas
through the country's mountainous
terrain and all the way to its border
with china and russia the reason they've
chosen rail cars it becomes nearly
impossible for the u.s and its allies to
track which rail cars have missiles and
which ones don't
another way to surprise rivals go
underwater while some marine launches
are not new pyongyang said its latest
test in october showcased a missile with
advanced features like gliding skip
mobility
a submarine gives them one more creative
way of moving around and using up
intelligence resources as
the united states and its allies guess
where these missiles are
but it isn't known if north korea fired
the missile from an actual submarine or
from a submerged barge as pyongyang is
believed to have done in earlier tests
there's a big difference between testing
this type of technology and then have it
be reliably operational or useful in a
military context
north korean analysts say the recent
military muscle flexing still sends a
strong message
north korea and kim jong-un are still
walking this fine line they're not doing
something so extreme like a nuclear test
or an icbm launch that really would draw
the wrath of the entire world
but it has the effect of just reminding
the us and south korea in particular
that we're not going to stop until we
get recognition
in the international world
the biden administration has said it's
willing to hold talks any time with
pyongyang but in a speech at the weapons
exhibit kim said the u.s couldn't be
trusted
so if and when talks do re-emerge with
south korea or the u.s they can promise
to stop doing these types of tests in
return for some type of goody be it
sanctions relief or humanitarian
assistance or
a peace declaration but these weapons
tests beyond sharpening north korea's
ability to defend itself and perhaps
intimidate u.s allies in the region it
also gives them a chip at the bargaining
table